au départ
bonsoir denis secrètement j'ai rêvé
qu'il nous sorte un ex-aequo tellement
magnifique dans ce film c'est un film
collectif donc voilà il aurait dû
inventer un césar pour 3 on sait que ça
existe pas amélie josiane melville
françois tous les autres quelle fierté
d'être faire partie de ce film vraiment
par deux fois on a essayé d'empêcher la
sortie du film et des huissiers de
justice qui sont venus dans les salles
de cinéma aux avant-premières pour
prendre des notes pour chercher quelque
chose à retourner contre nous c'était
assez violent mais je me suis dit alors
en fait si le cinéma encore ce pouvoir
là de faire trembler alors on peut être
fier un peu quand même
on peut être fier de ce qu'ont fait
parfois je pense surtout en fait à ces
trois personnages qu'on interprète denis
melville et moi il existe vraiment il
s'appelle alexandre françois pierre
emmanuel voilà ils ont ils ont subi des
abus sexuels pendant leur enfance et
c'est devenu des héros pour moi c'est
des héros parce que ils ont réussi à
parler à affronter le regard des autres
le le mensonge le mépris d'un grand
courage une grande détermination et
c'était une immense responsabilité que
d'avoir d'avoir ça a joué
[Musique]
juste petite parenthèse un barbare a été
relaxé on attend le jugement pourpre et
n'a donc les artistes ne font pas la
justice mais au moins s'ils peuvent dire
des choses que le silence tente
d'étouffer ses biens placés çà voilà
c'est déjà ça pierre-emmanuel tu m'a
confié ton histoire c'est un rôle
immense intime ta douleur tarage ton
espoir ta force de vite à force de lutte
pour tout ça merci merci merci à vous je
vous embrasse et au mien